[Música]
listo para pedir un favor muy grande si
ven que esto es muy apasionado si de
pronto en que me metí muy apasionado en
estas charlas no me paren
bueno florecita
florecita no solamente es una persona
espectacular sino que hace el mejor
capuchino de latinoamérica
lo necesita entre un día que estaba
teniendo y un personaje que entró a mi
compañía quería hablar de cultura mucha
gente le gusta ir a hablar de cultura
nuestra compañía no me explico por qué y
este personaje entró flores cities
buenos días cómo están y yo por supuesto
estoy viendo a florecita por primera vez
o las florecitas y este hombre se asusta
y dice no pues se emocionó o la
florecita como estas florecitas lo miran
los ojos y le dice divirtiéndome
y es que así funciona nuestra compañía
así funciona nuestra organización
tenemos hemos desarrollado una cultura
tan especial tan enfocada en las
personas que definitivamente al que
encontremos trabajando lo echamos se
tiene que ir y todo empezó hace 21 años
en 1995 decidimos romper el status quo
decidimos que no queríamos tener una
compañía no queremos una empresa vamos a
crear una cultura vamos a crear un
estado de ánimo vamos a crear un
comportamiento colectivo y alrededor de
eso vamos a desarrollar
y yo les digo romper el status quo
porque en 1995 hablar de felicidad
hablar de desarrollar las personas era
romper el status quo hoy todo mundo
habla de eso es un tema pues que la
gente le gusta hablar y echarle si hay
de todo pero imagínense eso hace 21 años
entonces empezamos a desarrollar esto y
esta cultura que fue la fuimos
disfrutando todos porque nosotros no
sabemos trabajar es un tema que no
sabemos cómo se funciona y nosotros
pasamos de vender productos y servicios
a desarrollar soluciones y enfocarnos en
productividad de clientes por supuesto
es una promesa fuerte una promesa que se
hace con integrantes desarrollados
y es que en nuestra compañía no hay
empleos no empleados porque nosotros en
la organización no creemos en la
amplitud nosotros creemos que las
compañías no deben tener empleado
empleado bien emplear y emplear es usar
y nosotros no usamos nosotros
desarrollamos esta cultura que fuimos
creando la fuimos creando de una forma
tan sencilla y trabajo y haciéndolo tan
consistentemente que a hoy 21 años
después fuimos capaces de acomodarlo en
una servilleta porque negocio o cultura
que no se puede exponer en una
servilleta no sirve yo creo que las
cosas tienen que ser siempre tienen que
ser claras para que funcione vamos a
hablar un poquito de la cultura la
cultura se llama vida y tiene tres
componentes esos tres componentes son el
primero es lo fundamentales es la razón
por la que nos levantamos todas las
mañanas es el por qué es lo que nos hace
ser y es
tiene tres aspectos básicos el primer
aspecto por supuesto es el desarrollo de
las personas las personas la gente el
mayor activo que puede tener cualquier
empresa la mayor oportunidad que puede
tener cualquier empresa y el segundo por
supuesto cuando tenemos personas así
como pasamos de vender productos a
enfocarnos en soluciones pues es la
productividad de los clientes cuando
tenemos integrantes desarrollados somos
capaces de hacer promesas difíciles de
cumplir para otras
empresas y para nosotros en el día a día
y por supuesto la tercera parte del
objetivo es ventas y las utilidades que
en la mayoría de las compañías son una
meta para nosotros es una consecuencia
la segunda parte lo conceptual
es los tres pilares tenemos tres pilares
básicos primero en la gente por supuesto
la actitud cómo nos comportamos cómo
vivimos cómo hacemos para ir juntos y
meternos en retos juntos y hemos creado
un método un método muy especial de este
método
este método se llama igual que la
cultura es el método vida y vida una
palabra muy bonita es una palabra corta
es una palabra que dice mucho es una
palabra que refleja demasiado y no
solamente es una palabra hermosa sino
que también es una palabra que tiene una
secuencia secuencial labbé de vida es la
ve de visualizar cuando no va a
prometerle un cliente que se va a
enfocar en su productividad pues lo
tiene que conocer visualizar es
simplemente el hecho de aprender el
lenguaje del cliente el lenguaje del
interlocutor ya sea un cliente interno o
un cliente externo porque cuando uno
aprende el lenguaje pasa algo
extraordinario uno lo habla y de un
momento a otro conecta se genera un
momento de inspiración que es la y
genera un momento extraordinario un
momento donde donde logramos conectar
con un cliente o con las personas con
las que hacemos negocios nosotros no
hacemos negocios con logos
y esa es esa conexión genera momentos de
información muy fuerte y toda esa
información que empieza a fluir porque
cuando hay conexión la gente quiere
hablar
nos da un espacio espectacular para
desarrollar es la de desarrollar que
desarrollar propuestas desarrollar
relaciones desarrollar momentos y por
supuesto las relaciones que se
desarrollan se desarrollan a largo plazo
estas tres primeras partes son como el
tema comercial es como como esa relación
comercial que logramos tener con los
clientes y como son relaciones basadas
en una promesa como prometimos cuando
visualizamos nos comprometimos con algo
pues esta la que es la de actuar es
cumplir la promesa y cuando cumplimos la
promesa lo que estamos logrando es
deleitar y es que en la cultura vida nos
da muchos gustos los clientes
satisfechos están como gorditos no nos
gusta un cliente satisfecho es un
cliente que simplemente fue a comprar
algo y se lo entregamos es un cliente
que se va a fácil cliente deleitado es
un fan
es una especie de funk es alguien que
quiere quedarse es alguien que quiere
más alguien que quiere interactuar más
allá y eso nos lleva al tercer pilar que
es el de la estrategia y la estrategia
en nuestra organización es muy chistosa
nosotros pues no tenemos ya sea ganar
dado cuenta no tenemos planeación
estratégica ni visión y misión y además
tengo una cultura y tenemos una
estrategia simpatiquísima tiene dos
palabras cabe en una tarjetita conectar
deleitar porque cuando ustedes ven el
método si lo aplicamos bien si tenemos
los integrantes desarrollados que
apliquen el método conectar y alentar no
son dos palabras simples son dos
palabras muy poderosas
y por supuesto está lo operacional
porque claro seguramente muchos de
ustedes si me pasa muchísimo cuando
cuando hablamos de estos temas porque
son temas que a la gente le atraen y es
como hablar bonito ese señor es tan
divino es decir dice unas cosas
encantador no pasa es que cuando uno
dice cosas de éstas más vale que las
cumpla más vale que tengan lógica por
eso les voy a hablar del cómo lo
operacional las tres fases y son tres
fases de implementación entonces llamó
dar el lujo en una charla te de sacar un
tablero y
nosotros todos pertenecemos a un entorno
todos pertenecemos a un entorno un
entorno donde hay los productores los
fabricantes donde están las empresas los
proveedores perdón la empresa los
clientes y por supuesto esos clientes
tienen clientes
y como hablamos de tres fases de
implementación todo esto es una cadena
de suministro
el reto es convertir esta cadena de
suministro es una cadena de valor donde
todos ganemos correcto y normalmente
pero la primera fase siempre arrancará
en el desarrollo de integrantes
y como he hablado tanto de las personas
y el desarrollo pues hablemos
rápidamente que es eso lo primero que
nos une a los integrantes son los
valores los valores es eso que nos hace
estar juntos los valores los sacamos
entre todos entre todos en esa época lo
hemos hemos ido reforzando cuando hablo
de esa época éramos 45 personas hoy
somos 760 en esa época todos nos
dedicamos a sacar cuál es que era lo que
nos hacía sentir bien qué era lo que nos
hacía estar juntos que era que era lo
que teníamos que hacer y sacamos
nuestros valores son nueve valores y lo
vivimos tenemos el valor de la equidad
muy característico de que todo el mundo
gane tenemos el valor del respeto el
valor del compromiso el de la felicidad
el de crear ambientes de diversión en la
empresa y de ahí sale que aquí
encontramos trabajando luchamos y este
valor por supuesto como está relacionado
con las personas hay otro tema
es el de los talentos y los talentos no
son esas cosas que identifican a las
personas nosotros hicimos la prueba de
gallup que nos da cinco talentos los
cinco talentos cuando los desarrollamos
lo que sacamos al frente son nuestras
fortalezas la fortaleza es lo que nos
hace sentir bien eso que nos hace
divertirnos y en el caso de la de los
talentos hay una cosa muy especial
también cuando uno reconoce sus talentos
también honra los de los otros y detrás
de los cinco talentos que todos tenemos
hay otra tanda de talentos hacia abajo
esas son las debilidades
resulta que cuando uno trabaja las
debilidades logra ser menos débil cuando
no trabajar los talentos y las
fortalezas es más fuerte pero cuando
honra las de otros entonces tengo socios
esos talentos que tienen otros marcan
mis debilidades entonces yo tengo socios
para mis debilidades y eso es otra eso
es una energía muy especial al interior
de los integrantes porque entonces
armamos equipos por naturaleza no
necesitamos y nos queremos hacemos
salones vida para juntar talentos esto
por supuesto nos lleva hay que que
ayudarlo con la capacitación en la
capacitación es capacitación personal es
la que es profesional la relacionada con
la labor y por supuesto la capacitación
personal que es tenemos clases de salsa
que se llaman aquí peleando y tenemos
clases de reflexología cosas que sean
los integrantes que las compartimos
entre todos y tenemos momentos de todos
y esto nos lleva a un crecimiento
profesional y personal muy especial en
la organización la gente crece hacia
arriba o sea verticalmente vas creciendo
la crece en las compañías ya somos cinco
compañías o crece horizontalmente
cada vez es más de lo que es cada vez
quiero ser mejor en lo que sé hacer y
para eso pues reforzamos mucho la
capacitación pero todo es muy
relacionado con las personas las
creencias y con los con los ejercicios
que hacemos y por supuesto está el
bienestar
en el bienestar
haití se bienestar el bienestar es bien
estar y los bienes y nosotros el
bienestar lo manejamos muy bien otros
nadie externo ni tenemos un director de
bienestar bienestar algo que creamos
juntos ambientamos todos nosotros mismos
por ejemplo si una de las mujeres y
somos una empresa ingeniería con el 45%
mujeres ingenieras muchas de ellas y
cuando una mujer quiere ir al
al pararse él representa al baño y
encuentra un cajón donde estaba un
secador y una plancha porque y un título
que dice para que te sientas mejor a la
hora que quieras eso es un tema de
bienestar bienestar la cultura son temas
de hechos
eso nos lleva por supuesto a la familia
y la familia pues es muy sencillo cuando
una persona se está divirtiendo todo el
día y llega a la casa pues el tema de la
conversación es como me divertí cuando
una persona trabaja todo el día y llega
a la casa simplemente dicen no le hable
nuevo papá que llegó muy prado no le
hagan a su mamá que llegó muy cansada no
le hablen está ubicada cuando nos llega
un día que se divirtió pues llega a
compartir y nosotros invitamos a la
familia a la compañía a hablar primero
ale las gracias por el integrante que
tenemos que es de esa familia y segundo
también para compartir con ellos quiénes
somos como somos y por qué somos así
porque es integrante llegar a la casa
muerto risa hablar del tema y por
supuesto esto está todo relacionado con
la felicidad y si yo soy un hombre feliz
no sé ser de otra forma y la felicidad
es una decisión
la felicidad no es algo que uno busca la
felicidad en la organización nuestra no
es un tema es un tema muy serio no
charlamos con eso es un tema bastante
importante porque la felicidad es un
tema que se vive es una decisión o no
decir por qué es que no quiere decir que
no hay retos no hay situaciones
complejas pero una situación compleja
desde la felicidad se atiende muy
difícil que una situación compleja desde
este maldito país por ejemplo cierto
entonces ahora vamos a la segunda fase
que la segunda fase está aquí la segunda
fase nosotros llamamos la fase de la
acción cierto y ustedes han visto que la
gran mayoría de la empresas funcionan es
en este pedacito
en este pedacito que pasa en este
pedacito pues el cliente tiene una
demanda uno tiene unos productos y
servicios las empresas cierto y por
supuesto se habla este lenguaje esta
empresa le dice a esta que es
maravillosa que los productos son los
mejores que son el líder en el mercado
como todo el mundo y el 50 por ciento de
la conversación es acerca de ellos y el
50 por ciento de la conversación de este
sillón y eso y yo toda la plata pero es
que aquí hay otros cuatro que son my man
e igual de elocuentes que usted también
son líderes y también tienen
maravillosos productos y servicios y
también están diciendo entonces eso lo
que hace es transportar esta
conversación a una hoja excel el sitio
más peligroso para las empresas porque
el tema es precio y las guerras de peso
son horrendas entonces nosotros
decidimos en la segunda parte que la
elección aplicar el método y aplicar el
método muy sencillo no nos interesa este
lenguaje de 50/50 nos interesa este
lenguaje aquí donde nosotros realmente
como empresa visualizamos que es
importante para accidente y el cliente
de nuestro cliente porque aquí es donde
estas presencias o en todo el lenguaje
de nosotros es aquí
donde el ciento por ciento de lo que
discutimos es acerca de lo que es
importante para este señor por eso hay
que visualizar en esta conversación este
temita desaparece pasa a un a una
conversación distinta y pasa una
prioridad diferente y esto normalmente
cuando lo hacemos bien con gente
empoderada con gente feliz gente que
está bien capacitada y que está
desarrollada normalmente lo que es lo
que pasa que logramos conectar hasta
aquí y cuando esto pasa se devuelve esta
magia porque esto no deja esto permea y
cuando esto permea este señor dice guau
qué más podemos hacer eso es un cliente
deleitado cierto porque un cliente
satisfecho es uno que te sienta otra vez
aquí cada sentada y cuando pasa eso nos
movimos movilizamos a la tercera parte
cual es la tercera parte la tercera fase
de nuestro le llamamos la fase en la
cultura de la atracción y la fase de la
atracción es cuando todos los jugadores
entran porque porque esto genera un
crecimiento exponencial
la cultura bien aplicada a la cultura
como esencia hace crecer a las compañías
exponencialmente y los proveedores lo
sienten y entonces el color pregunta qué
está pasando ahí porque está creciendo
la compra de ustedes porque está
creciendo la demanda y nosotros
simplemente les contamos cuando eso pasa
pasa una magia especial él dice permiso
que yo quiero ser parte de esto y se
genera esta belleza de de energía que es
espectacular que solamente para si somos
no aprendemos el método y no tenemos
integrantes desarrollados pero esta
energía no para cuando la cultura es es
consistente y tiene coherencia y esto es
fantástico porque esto realmente es lo
que hace que las empresas crezcan y para
darles un ejemplo nuestra cultura ha
hecho que nuestra organización crezca 40
veces en ventas 15 veces en integrantes
y 20 veces en evitar eso le fascina
muchas las personas que no entienden
mucha cultura pero sí de compañías
entonces
porque hacemos esto nosotros simplemente
hemos hecho esto por una creencia fuerte
una creencia sólida 700 personas 760
personas que pensamos que otra empresa
es posible y que otro país es posible
por eso los invito a que algún día si
tienen el interés suficiente nos tomemos
un capuchino de florecita y hablemos de
un país distinto de un mejor país y de
una mejor empresa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]